[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
first time i ever heard the n-word i was
at uh
i was in i was in first grade and these
black kids came into our neighborhood we
lived in like a poor white neighborhood
and there was a poor black neighborhood
like across across across nebraska or
not nebraska
i forget well dude that's pretty far
then if you're no no no no no no that
was the street name not the oh right on
bro yeah and so damn this dude did not
live by black people if he said they
[ __ ] lived a state away
so i'm like wow they were in nebraska
and we were in florida and it was scary
man i gotta be honest with you it was
touch and go at times
i mean we heard stories oh yeah the
rumor mill i saw a note in a bottle one
time in the river
it was crazy watch out for the blacks
they're coming
up over your shoulders
i'm not saying i'm famous but i
definitely
that was wet it was almost wet now smell
your mic no
it's bad it's that bad for sure yeah um
then smell the tail it's my favorite
thing in the world are you [ __ ] me i
don't know why it makes me so happy but
it makes me so happy uh you ever fart in
the back sorry go ahead no go fart in
the bath but then hold the bubbles so
cup it in your hand underneath the water
since i was 11 so i don't know
you ever take a
bath have you ever been sponging
yourself off
i started in bed with leanne yesterday
in vegas
no pants on shut it onto the sheets
and then had to run you know like
tippy-toe it into the bathroom and then
just rifled it out
hold on i'm gonna show you the night
before that's so nasty yeah just you
tell you what's going on i was i was
vegan for a while
for a while describe a while everyone
has this kind of subjective roughly
three days okay
roughly three days with a few cheap
meals
that's a good run i didn't know this is
part of that wait i told you the health
book you're writing no we were i was
drunk at an airport it sounded like you
were going to vomit right now
i was drunk at an airport and i'm
[ __ ] sweating now yeah i was drunk at
an airport and i was like i bet i could
go [ __ ] vegan and they're like you
couldn't go vegan i go yeah i can do it
everything i put my mind to yeah and so
we get on the plane and i'm like [ __ ] it
i'm going vegan i'm gonna lose some
weight go vegan
so i'm drinking a double tea dose of
soda she brings me a beer with it
and then lunch comes around and i go
what do you have meat and pasta is there
any cheese on the pasta and she goes no
i said is there any meat on the pasta
she goes no i should go with the pasta
so the guy next to me is kind of
watching me he gets the meat and we
start eating and he goes hey man
are you like allergic to cheese i go no
i'm vegan
and he goes really i said yeah he goes
you know there's egg and pasta right and
i go and i didn't know that
he goes how long have you been eating
pasta i go my whole life
and you call yourself vegan this is
what's wrong with you people and he
starts [ __ ] jumping into my lifestyle
choice on an airplane style choice by
the way he didn't know i've only been
vegan for like 45 minutes
you don't tell him
i just kept eating the pasta i had to go
to baptist camp when i was 10 it was
called kids camp it was a little [ __ ]
weird
we weren't even baptized by watching a
kid get molested my first [ __ ] day
what the hell wow man not not hardcore
unless they just dog tied naked in the
shower
what the [ __ ] i don't want to say yeah
that's the first time i've ever learned
about compound bows too by hazing and
somebody was getting hit wasn't even
hazing straight up yeah that's a little
bit different i mean you call it sexual
assault now but yeah
i remember just going like getting in my
bed going i hope i'm not next yes
i used to have a joke about that and i
go um i do you ever see the same person
twice in one day like you and you're
like oh my god
yeah i saw this asian lady 15 times in
one day she was everywhere she was at
the
cleaners she was at the nail salon
she cut me off in traffic three times
yeah and so i'm not mr fax you know like
yeah it's like like we go on joe rogan's
show
i feel like i'm ill-equipped to respond
to any topic because i'm i'm not well
read on it or or for me i'll end up
reading a book and then getting on there
and you can it's clear i read one book
and i'm like have you ever told you
about king leopold you come to my house
looking for problems
you're going to leave there a limp and
[ __ ] i'll tell you that much
i think about that i think about someone
i just got guns i got to go yeah oh no i
got uh you just sit there all night wait
like dude i have a joke i have a joke
about it in my act about there's no
better feeling than drinking with your
gun in the middle of the night
just waiting for [ __ ] to go down
two in the morning with a glock on your
lap just going come on [ __ ] make
sure that [ __ ] don't go off by mistake
uh i don't put bullets in my gun
get the magazine out of it name a
country i'll do an accent oh this is a
fun game go ahead argentina ah argentina
there you go
really good okay okay okay ready i'll
say all right
hold on do a full sentence hi i'm from
argentina i'm so sorry my cow got into
your yard
however let me grab my boroderos i will
catch him bring him back over to my
house i'll make a little bit of a that
green stuff i like to make and put on my
meat
and then we will have some
argentinian beef all right next one
friends friends
yo
i'm so sorry i gave you herpes
i am smoking and i could not talk
properly as i drank my wine and came on
your teeth we we miss you
very good how about australia okay all
right mate
let me get these aborigines out of here
get my kangaroo
and i'll catch this cookie and i'm gonna
throw it in the back of my
big truck
you're nailing it keep going germany
[Laughter]
i'm from germany
i like to be tied up and [ __ ] on
that is my thing
because i'm from germany kind of fading
off there but yeah good first first
three greenland greenland
hello
i am from greenland
very nice to have you in my country a
lot of people assume that iceland has
green stuff and greenland
but it's not that way i'm from greenland
would you like a piece of whale
keep going russia but
hello i am russian are you the machine
you are okay i think did my accent
follow your part back to france
i think i'm going back to france
nailing it mailing it
korea korea i'm not going to do that one
do it in honor of that no no no no no no
no no hi i'm bobby bobby lee i take my
shirt off i have a small dick all right
when i started my podcast i was like
maybe i'll do it solo just do it solo
you don't need guests yeah i was like
and i already said this yeah and i did a
couple solo i go bill they're not good
and he goes they're not gonna be he was
like let them be bad for like a year and
then they'll get better and then they'll
get really good and then you won't even
think about it and then your writing on
stage will be so strong and i was like
yeah i think i'm just gonna have guests
they tried to bring everybody loves
raymond to russia uh-huh and it just
didn't work because they were like he
was like who let's their woman talk like
that
you hit her you hit her a little bit and
say [ __ ] you don't talk to me like that
the body shots world tour
no blacks allowed
[Laughter]
wow that's i did not make that that is
not sanctioned crazy i know i'm gonna
spend this whole podcast just going okay
that's not real
do what's awful is when when people
comment on it yeah in the comment
section yeah oh bert this is
uh you're such a fat racist [ __ ]
and then and then new fans that have
just found me from netflix defend me
yeah they're like he's a good guy he's a
it's a joke and there's no racist joke
right i don't even have a racist joke in
my act yeah and there's nothing there
and they're like it's jokes if you can't
learn how to take a joke he makes fun of
everyone equally i'm like i'm not
thinking about anybody it's a picture of
my daughter
gary valentine is someone that i used to
get so drunk with one time i took a shot
out of a candle i thought it was a shot
and i shot the candle and burned my face
when you're something crazy when i took
the life insurance exam you take one
over the phone and the guy the kid
answers the phone and he's how he goes
i'm going to walk you through all the
questions they ask you if you've ever
done drugs if you've ever
drank alcohol i get done all my
questions and and he goes uh
he goes okay i think we're done for now
i'm gonna end the recording i went oh
thank you and he does recording goes it
was a pleasure meeting the machine and i
was like [ __ ]
i just i'm sure he listened to my
answers like i very seldomly drink
i've never tried drugs or whatever my
[ __ ] you know it isn't comedy when
you have a theater full of people that
want to hear one thing and you tell them
that one thing
that's not it imagine
it feels like a cult how much fun would
comedy be if you just if if you were
like all right well what am i saying i
kind of do that like i just go out and
like what if they said they just want to
watch you drink tito's
i was like wait
what if people wanted to see you drunk
yeah and you got drunk what was that
just wanted to see you with your shirt
and tell the machine story wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait throw me
in the briar back first grade i was not
fighting anyone i was wearing a
loincloth and knee-high moccasins oh
yeah and so um
he's fighting your sexuality bro
my dad's like get him some knee pads
he's gonna be sucking dick
so uh so
yeah so he's gonna need knee pads to do
it what a [ __ ]
that's a crazy part man
what about the good old days man well
you would suck kick your knees and just
[ __ ] dick be a man about it yeah bro
support the union you freak
what kind of gay guy puts on knee pads
like a man man a backup gay dude you
mind if i pull my socks up
i'm old school i still got hot man i'm
still playing 45 000 unread emails
yeah you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you thought
will smith's going to [ __ ] you oh yeah
you never told you that no yeah my first
development deal uh i was
over broke yeah with overbrook and uh i
grew up i was working the [ __ ] door
and they were like will smith wants to
meet you and i was so i go up meet him
[ __ ] awesome i tell him how much i
love hip hop and how he's black and he's
i love black people
and uh and then he doesn't and then he
goes let's go to the movies i was like
okay
and so i called my dad well and i was
like and he's like on he's like what are
you doing tonight i said i'm going to
movies with will smith he's like on a
date i go no it's like no just sounds
like that
even when he said let's go to the movies
i just was like
go to the movies like that didn't seem
odd he's like yeah planet hollywood me
and you and i was like
i was like oh this is well dead he did
tell me to make sure my cummerbund
matched his corsage
and so my dad's like buddy this is
called a casting couch these guys are so
famous and they [ __ ] so many beautiful
women that the only thing that turns
them on is to [ __ ] young boys make a
make a straight boy decide to go gay
that's that's sexy for them i was like
that's [ __ ] impossible dad he goes
what's more likely the fact that you're
so talented that will smith the biggest
movie star in the world wants to do a
sitcom about you after doing stand-up
for only six months or or he's tired of
[ __ ] i'm like oh my god i'm getting
[ __ ] in the ass
so i show up
charlie mack is there charlie mack was
his uh yeah first at the limo yep for
his bodyguard and he sees me he's like
yo dude you burnt i said yeah he goes
downstairs go downstairs all black dudes
like 13 black dudes
i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
these 13 black dudes to get to win
charlie mack i'm sure he's bringing
jazzy jeff that's 15 dudes
and there's all small room as big as
this as big as this room
and a folding table center curtains are
all around it
so wilkin comes in with jazzy jeff i
swear to god they walk in will's like
guys this is the guy i told you about
this is bert and they all just start
walking towards me i'm like all right
i'll suck their dicks
i'm gonna work them all over yeah
like i'll [ __ ] start
like lucy in the chocolate factory and
so uh
then a curtain opens and there's a
private movie theater and we watched
american pie and at the very end this is
the interesting part at the very end
uh we got we got drunk and we had
[ __ ] dinner and laughed in the big
couches and
watched it with black people so they're
all talking throughout it
and it's like fun the funnest thing i've
ever been a part of that [ __ ]
and uh
you get another laugh off it
let me start calling you apple pie all
night
you ever think that maybe will smith did
[ __ ] you that night but he used the men
in black memory eraser thing on you at
the end
so at the very end he goes uh he's like
so what did you think it was and by the
way i it's really nerve-wracking to
watch a movie with when you're going to
develop a show with a guy because i was
wondering if he was gaging my sense of
humor or trying to read like this is
what white kids like i'm with a white
kid where is he laughing what is he you
know yeah so i was really uncomfortable
the whole [ __ ] movie i was like but i
had a good time i laughed and then uh he
goes what'd you think i was like it's
good movie i really like it i think you
know he goes no no no no would you think
about uh the guys
i was like oh they're really cool
they're very nice and he goes no man
you said you're a hip-hop star you're a
hip-hop fan i was like yeah he's like
you're sitting next to cool modi that's
biz marquee big daddy can't like the
whole [ __ ] 80s hip-hop roster
all-stars came to hang out with me and
you didn't recognize anything i didn't
recognize all audio you always heard
them well they're all black guys yeah
audio for one but racism [ __ ] they're
all black guys you ever be on the train
with like 20 black guys and you don't
make eye contact with anybody and you're
just like okay let's my stop this is my
stop actually me i'm always going to
stare them all down and see if anyone
leaves cool mode
i'm sorry guys we're going to do a
quickie there's a dad in our
neighborhood who uh you'd play [ __ ]
with him and if and if you lost the
letter instead of losing a letter you
had to kiss him
i remember being like hey
i remember illegal bro no [ __ ]
back then you just didn't know you're
like ah i gotta kiss this down did you
get some lips or small of his back
i don't remember i want to say on the
cheek but maybe sometimes on the lips
i don't remember oh damn dude that's
even get that's is that gay or just
[ __ ] up i don't know remember you you
definitely did not want to miss shots
it really made competition [ __ ]
intense bro his team shot 70 percent
from three range i remember he'd make a
shot never be like [ __ ]
get the chapstick out
this idea that you shouldn't victim
blame them is absurd because we
literally victim blame with every dif if
you come home and there's something
spilled on the carpet
you are blaming well i guess the carpet
is would be the victim in that
circumstance but it doesn't matter
whatever the [ __ ] it is you victim blame
and and like did you just lay there
just get walked all over all day he was
[ __ ] [ __ ] you get walked on whole
[ __ ] day you never stand up for
yourself and now you got ketchup on you
you deserve it today i was going into a
meeting i saw two homeless guys and i
and uh
i
had a little windfall of cash in my
pocket like just random cash yeah so i
went up and gave them each 20 bucks i
said hey have a good fourth i don't even
think they knew it was the fourth was
coming up i don't know why it's a good
fourth like they were going to go oh we
should barbecue now but he just gave me
20 bucks and then i was like there we
did our good deed and i hope that that
changes something and then i don't know
why i'm telling this story but then
and then i walked i miss i missed the
entrance of the building and the one guy
the one the most lucid of the two was
the one who was like i think the
entrance are you looking for the
entrance it's that over there and so i
went the wrong way and then i came back
on a minute he was talking on his cell
phone
uh arranging plans for the weekend and
he had no cell phone
and i was like
and when did you guys start making love
or you'd already been making love no we
don't even make it yeah we
we had sex probably like five dates in
this back during sex in the city do you
remember that sex in the city run where
all guys thought all girls were [ __ ]
i remember thinking that though just
even looking on instagram so
there was a period where women were like
and that thing is still there but like
sex and the city came out and women are
like yeah i like to [ __ ]
oh i could see that like now we're in
control of our own [ __ ] and that
scared the [ __ ] out of me because i've
only had sex with six people women why
am i saying people wh women just [ __ ]
adult women too adult women they had to
put my daughter uh have somebody walk
her to a school bus for a couple months
after the jimmy
fallon thing i did with the when
everybody got mad about my michael vick
joke oh yeah what was your michael vick
joke he said michael jack was right
michael vick was right and dogs had it
coming
and he said i'm specifically not joking
don't take this as a comedy thing
[ __ ] but if i could just yeah for a
second everybody specifically
i know generally you can write this off
this is not one of those times this part
this part not a joke
[Laughter]
we were asking a doctor sex questions
but it was supposed to be fun
it's a black guy and he goes
i'm going to go off book for a second
hey doc for real can you get aids from
being straight and having sex
she's like definitely he's like
oh man
did you get [ __ ] with stand up early
once
[Music]
[Music]
you